le monde et son terrain de jeu mais à 51
ans
c'est lui qui va désormais en fixer les
règles après un détour par la
pétrochimie et le nucléaire
jacques baudot they le nouveau pdg du
groupe b club en toute simplicité
en fait vous baigner dans les souvenirs
d'enfance dans votre métier
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que ces
produits là ça date de très longtemps
quand j'ai commencé dans le jouet
j'avais peut-être dix ans environ 10 ans
à 10 ans a commencé
et oui mais bon un magasin de jouets
donc j'ai commencé à y aller j'allais
aider je faisais lire c'est une marche
analyse de recompter les produits j'aime
et orient je faisais les rayons j'étais
vraiment à fond toujours à fond même à
des kilomètres de la petite boutique
familiale de pontarlier depuis un mois
jacques bedos préside les destinées des
300 magasins de l'enseigné de leur 2300
salariés
un microcosme géant qu'ils maîtrisent
depuis bordeaux le berceau du groupe à
la volée toys'r'us et autre grande récré
liquide joué club affiche un chiffre
d'affaires en progression
une réussite qui tiendrait à son modèle
économique leur modèle c'est un modèle
en intégrer c'est à dire que tout est
géré depuis l'eau et ça remonte pas
depuis le bas nous elle contient la
coopérative permet d'avoir plein de
chefs d'entreprise qui chacun dans leur
région peuvent développer leur commerce
et leur unité joué club comme ils
l'entendent c'est à dire qu'ils vont
s'adapter au commerce local
ils vont mettre des bateaux plus tôt en
normandie est plutôt des chasse neige
dans le jura
au nouveau catalogue nouveau concept
nouvelle plate forme pour continuer à
maîtriser la donne jouéclub opère sa
mutation en interne depuis plusieurs
mois avec la volonté de promouvoir le
joueur français 7% à peine du marché une
bonne nouvelle pour les fournisseurs
franc comtois qui ont l'occasion de
faire équipe avec un pdg qui joue à
domicile